all right
so between seasons of council of geeks
you're going to get me
just me and i figure i might as well
launch directly into something that is
probably going gonna get me flamed or it
would if anybody was actually watching
how final fantasy vii
ruined the final fantasy game series
there's something i want to make
really really clear here i am not saying
that final fantasy vii is a bad game but
i'm talking about its impact on the
overall franchise let's
back up a little bit to the days before
number seven final fantasy one through
six the overall look stayed pretty much
the same small band of heroes saves the
world basic sort of outline and of
course there's the more superficial
things that kept recurring mughals
chocobos certain summoned characters etc
etc etc
and then final fantasy vii happened
in many ways still very much fits the
final fantasy mold it's got a similar
basic plot structure the music was still
by nobu uematsu and there were the
chocobos the summon beast the usual ray
of spells like fire ice bolt that was
all there but there were a lot
of big
big changes firstly
to the aesthetic in the leap
from traditional sprites to polygons
something got lost something specific
the design work
of yoshitaka amano the reason to have
someone like yoshitaka amino design your
characters and your creatures back in
the days of sprites was because you
can't make it look realistic so you need
to give it an artistic flourish as
graphics
got into 3d and then got better
that got lost
in favor of a general sense of realism
so talking aesthetics is all well and
good but let's talk about the materia
magic system it was really really clever
and it was a pretty dramatic
shift in how magic was handled the way
it was handled in one through six it was
all basically handled the same way
seven changed all that and
to rave reviews fans loved it critics
loved it
and
square took the wrong lesson
away from this we now have a completely
redesigned magic and or combat system
with every
single
entry
they hit it out of the park once but
boy there is no reason for them to be so
drastically redesigning it and it's
gotten to the point where with final
fantasy 13 what they ended up with was a
really really good combat system
and lousy characters and story they
actually forgot that some people
want to care about these characters
which brings us to
how final fantasy vii screwed up the way
these stories get told
seven brought in this aspect of mystery
of twists of
really convoluted stuff to the point
that at this moment in time i don't
think i could really properly articulate
exactly what the deal is
with cloud and sephiroth
it was complicated it was overly
complicated
especially in that story because the the
moments that everyone remembers like
when aerys is killed it has nothing to
do
with the ridiculous twists and cloud
isn't really what he said he was he's
actually this guy and there was this
zach
guy and uh who the heck even cares
nobody cares and we started getting some
really
really
convoluted stories i think final fantasy
8 is probably going to rank at the top
of that particular bit
because it's just
what is going on
in that game these characters and they
know each other and they grew up
together but they don't remember and
there's this witch who's not really a
witch but there is a witch there's this
other witch i just
strong setup confused execution
kind of became the standard for a lot of
the entries that came in after that wait
a minute what about final fantasy ix
that kind of went back to a lot of what
the older series had done doesn't that
throw a wrench in your theory nope
it doesn't and here's why
final fantasy 9
was an overcorrection final fantasy 8
definitely had its critics and
rightfully so there was very little
distinction between the characters
either in terms of personality
appearance or the way that they played
in combat the way that magic was handled
was kind of stupid you had the summons
which lasted forever
actually we're going to take a little
side trip on that issue right now that
was another thing that final fantasy 7
ruined because they got a little bit
carried away with their new graphic
capabilities they got bigger they got
more elaborate
and it just kind of snowballed from
there and it made square decide that
they were an indelible part of the
series and we must have them even if
they don't fit which got us to the point
where final fantasy 13.
shiva is a motorcycle what the hell
okay
coming back from that tangent so final
fantasy 9 was
aggressively nostalgic fans didn't
really respond to it and because they
swung the pendulum too far away from the
good innovations and the correct lessons
they should have learned from seven and
eight it just felt not like oh old
school fun more like well we were
progressing and now we've stepped back
and so they just dropped it and that
brings us to where we are with the
repeated redesign the loss of aesthetic
started with final fantasy vii got
cemented with the
good not great reaction to final fantasy
nine and there you have it and we're
here
because of final fantasy vii
and a developer
that took away the wrong lessons from a
massively successful and very good game
this council of geeks
is adjourned